hello it's cameron again founder of
stylecraft and a pro motion designer
with two decades of experience
it's great to have you join me in this
third video in my free workshop
how to design style frames in this video
i'm going to outline the exact blueprint
that you need to bring that final polish
to your style frames if you've ever been
confused about how
all the pieces of style frame design fit
together and more importantly
what goes into creating that finished
pro
level design and style frames this video
is for you in this video i'll show how
motion designers like you and me
can bring that final polish to your
style frames
[Music]
in video one we talked about how to
concept style for indesign so you can
have a
clear path to design in video 2
we then covered how to lay the design
foundation so you can easily build
style frames so if you haven't seen
those two videos
please go back and watch them now and
then
come back to this third video today i'm
going to build on what we
have already discussed by giving you the
complete
solution to bring that final polish to
your style frames
by the end of this video you'll have so
much clarity about pro
level style frame design and you'll see
how everything
fits together we've got a lot to cover
today so make sure
you're taking notes as you follow along
with this video anytime
you're trying to bring that final polish
to your style frames
it can be hard it can be challenging
because in the beginning
it's hard to really understand and to
know what to focus on
when doing that final polish like what
to focus in on
what details should be of concern what
effects you should use and so on and so
forth
even if you have experience with pro
level style frame design already
you're always looking for that 80 20.
you don't have time to waste so you want
to find that 20
that's going to produce 80 of the
results and that's why design polish
is going to deliver results quickly
so let's do this okay so here we are in
concept one and this is where we left
off from video two
uh this is the style frame that we left
at that point
so now we're in the final polish stage
and this is you know bringing it all
together this is where we make it look
really pro it already looks really
good and that's very important as i
talked about in the last video that you
have a solid foundation for your design
this is a solid foundation so now all we
have to do
is that last 20 percent to really bring
this guy
into the spotlight okay so here we are
and the first
first something i'm going to do is
obviously this
rocket over here just doesn't fit with
everything else it's too
um there's too many highlights there's
too much um
not enough contrast okay you can see
there's a lot of contrast happening here
not enough here so that's the first
thing i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go to my
rocket
and it's set to add and i'm gonna change
it here to maybe overlay
shift plus to go down soft light
hard light there we go there is the
contrast
i was looking for next i'm going to do
is on this plane here i'm going to scale
this plane up a little bit
i want to be a little bit more
prevalent in here and i also want to
kind of overlap
these two frames here and i'm going to
bring it above this
type there we go
that looks pretty nice so it kind of
brings the type the letter back here
a little bit more in the background and
the plane a little bit more into the
foreground really like that a lot
i'm also going to take
these two layers i'm actually going to
go ahead and unparent josh apple from
editor so they're two separate layers
and i'm going to select
the tape sheet here make sure i have the
right tape sheet
all three selected and i'm just going to
pull them over a little bit more so
again they overlap
i don't know what happened there i want
them to overlap a little bit more
in this frame so it's okay for elements
to overlap it kind of you know it makes
a little bit more visually interesting
that way so things aren't like
divided into into compartments i'm also
going to scoot this guy over a little
bit
i still like that a lot i'm also going
to
select editor and bring it up here
maybe actually select the tape here and
bring it a little bit over here and
maybe josh apple
i don't want apple to hit the line there
that's looking pretty good
yeah i like that a lot so now as we're
starting to so the
the frame is looking a lot better one
thing that you're going to immediately
notice here
is look at all the analog
the grunge look that's going on here
with the with the text okay like if you
look at the text here
it's very muddied it's
imperfect there's a lot of things
happening to this text it's kind of
scribbled out
same up with this text up in here and
then you look at this editor josh apple
text
and it's very crisp okay so we don't
want that so this is one of those things
where you have to really pay attention
to all of the elements here and
and really blend them in together
and finishing and polishing is is all
about blending these elements together
really making them sit well together
so one thing we're going to do here this
is a trick is we're just going to take
our text and
go to blur and sharpen and a lot of
different blurs here we're just going to
go with a basic
gaussian blur and i'm zooming in here
and i'm looking at this text i'm also
looking at this text so
this text does not have to be as muddied
as this text because
this text is very important this is a
this is a frame that we're going to see
the editor's name so we want it to stand
out
so it doesn't have to be quite so
grunge like and dirty and trashed as
this text
but i want a little bit to happen there
so i'm going to go
to usually a value between like two and
five
is okay so four is too much
two is not enough
2.5 is looking pretty good to me i'm
going to go to josh apple as well
gaussian blur we'll go 2.5
maybe because this text a little bit
bigger let's just go half
0.5 more so we're at three and it looks
you know pretty blurry here but if we
zoom out
and here we're at 100
um it's looking better right it's
looking just not
so crisp right we just want those edges
to be a little bit softer
so that's nice and the next i'm going to
do is i
i also don't want this text to be
completely horizontally straight across
right it's too perfect again like look
at this tape that it's
sitting with and the tape you know has
this kind of
bent edge down here it's got a bent edge
up here
so i want my text to kind of follow that
a little bit so the easiest way i'm
going to do that is i'm going to select
both
chunks of text both pieces of type right
click and just say pre-compose
and we'll call this text pre pc
for pre-comp and there we go
looking nice next i'm going to go up to
effect and
i'm going to go to distort
let's see here liquify i like the
liquify effects a lot
i feel like they're under used
and it's just basically like a brush so
if i have this brush and i start
painting
you can see here i'm just kind of
pushing text around
well i want my brush to be a little bit
bigger than this
so i'm gonna go over here to my
tool options and
just start increasing the size here
maybe something like that
and it doesn't have to be much right i
just i just want a little bit here
right so see that's already probably
enough for the editor it kind of bends
up there
just a little bit and i'm using this
push tool here there's a lot of
different tools inside of here
i'm just using the very basic push tool
and i'm going to bring
this text maybe bring up the radius a
little bit more here
so it covers the entire chunk of text
and we're just going to push it down
so that's that's too much
maybe just in here just a little bit
there
maybe push this up just a hair
and maybe the end here just pull it down
just a
little bit actually i don't want to undo
that
i think i like that yeah so again it's
very
very subtle but it just helps blend some
of these elements together i could you
know spend more time here and just
really kind of fine-tune some of these
but uh
you know it's looking pretty good
actually that's even a little bit better
i really like that a lot what else do we
have here so now let's start adding
some some elements over the top okay so
let's go and let's add a new adjustment
layer
and the first thing i'm going to add
here
is i want to add some noise and grain
and you may say okay well why do you
want to add grain there's already so
much
noise and grain happening here but
there's not any
happening down in here um i could just
add some
some text some noise actually let's go
ahead and do that well i take that back
let's just try this let's add the grain
first thing it's going to do is going to
show me a preview box here i'm going to
go to final output so that's the entire
frame
and you know you can't really tell too
much that there's
extra grain happening here if i turn it
off
and on you can see a little bit happen
there mainly i want to get some
happening inside this text here so if i
turn it off on
off on maybe let's increase the
intensity
just a bit and let's just
go with that's a little bit too much
there
let's try the third one maybe the first
one
nope too much maybe a kodak vision
and let's go back down to one
off on off on
i'm also going to make it monochromatic
i'm taking the color out of that grain
so if i zoom out here and i go
off on you can see it's
very very subtle right so now there's
just a little bit of grain here in the
text
helps kind of blend it in there with
everything else
i could also add some texture to that
text if i wanted to but i think for this
one
i'm going to leave it off a little trick
that you could also do here actually
i'll show you that in the next concept
i'll leave that for the next concept
so that's looking pretty good uh let's
go back to our adjustment layer we'll
call this
effects actually we'll call it effects
one uh what else i also like to do a
little bit
of coloring here so let's go
to color correction lumetri color this
is very powerful
and for luma tree let's go to creative
and let's just pick
sl big that's a nice one to start with
so that's already really nice
just off the top because everything was
already kind of colored even though it's
black and white it was at a base level
everything was matching up very nicely
so
just adding this overall color just
really helps bring it together
let's drop the intensity down to 50.
yeah just a little bit there just a
little bit
really basic and it works i like it a
lot
we could also just play around a little
bit with faded film
maybe something like 25
you know that's a matter of choice maybe
i'll just go back down to
10. yeah i like that that works
we're also going to add
chromatic aberrations so at the time of
this recording
in the last year two years
actually three years maybe chromatic
aberration has been very popular in
motion design and it kind of just brings
back that analog feel there's a lot of
different ways you can apply
chromatic aberration i personally love
using sapphire effects for that
um but a lot of you may not have
sapphire so there is a plug-in by
plug-in everything
it's called quick chromatic aberration
2. this is a free plugin
okay so it's really easy to use you just
apply it to
the top of your layer and i pretty much
like to leave it at a default
value but a lot of times i'll add just a
blur of one
and uh really digging that so that's
with
that's without so it's very very subtle
again
but uh but it works right
okay so we're gonna add one more effect
and we'll do that just with a new
adjustment layer
the reason i'm adding another adjustment
layer is i find that sometimes
this effect can be kind of um
i don't know it can be very sensitive to
what other effects are applied to the
same adjustment layer it's just my own
personal
um experience with it maybe it's the
version of after effects i'm on i don't
know
but that is under effect distort and
we're going to use
optics compensation a lot of times when
film cameras are used they have you know
they have curved glass to them so i'm
just going to add just a slight bit of
curve here we're talking about
10 a value of 10 and we're going to
reverse it
and there we go so very very very subtle
here so without
with without with so so subtle
but it's all in those details and there
my friend
is concept number one style frame
really dig it it looks great let's move
on to concept two
okay so here we are in concept two and
immediately i see some things i want to
change and that's something i should
mention
is that between the overall the
the foundation design the foundation of
the design
and then the polish i always like to
take a break
right i want to visually rest my eyes so
if i can give it an
entire day and say okay here's the
foundation i'm done working for today
i'll come back tomorrow
that's what i've done this time i've
come back the next day
and now i'm looking at this and saying
okay there are certain things about this
i don't like i
feel like it's too crowded right the
text is too crowded here
with some of these assets you know
overall i like it
but it's just a little bit too much
going on
so i'm just going to probably play a
little bit here with some of the
placements of these
different elements here it's just a
little bit too much
happening so
maybe something like that that's already
a little bit better
yeah i think i like that where that's at
here
and something else i want to do here is
i actually i'm going to do a process at
the end where i kind of color grade
everything together
so before i do that i always actually
want to bring the
saturation back up on this red
so it really stands out at the moment
i'm also looking at the texture and the
text
it was on overlay changed it to hard
light or soft light
so i think maybe i'll try hard light for
right now that might be too much
um something else i want to do is i want
to darken up the background i know the
background's already dark let's make it
darker so let's go up to
effect color correction curves
and we're just going to just click and
bring down
[Music]
the darkness of the background yeah so
we can still see it
actually that might be a little bit too
much let's also go up into our spotlight
hit a a and
typically i don't ever like to use like
a pure white light if you look at
lights typically they're never they're
usually like maybe like a blue
white or a yellowish white i'm going to
make this a little bit more of a grayish
white
and it's going to also kind of darken up
everything just a little bit more
that looks pretty nice something else
let's just actually go right in here to
the text
and let's go ahead and go ahead and
pre-compose this
we'll call it text pc just like before
when we do that
it immediately you know changes it goes
to a 2d layer it's lost
it's um it's not relating to the lights
anymore but all we have to do is
click on this little right guy right
here
and boom we're right back to having that
text
be in that 3d space so it's all we have
to do is collapse transformations
if you want you can also click here and
it's
i guess it's doubly 3d at this point
sometimes that's what i do
let's go into effect and let's do like
what we did last time let's go to blur
and sharpen
gaussian blur and let's just zoom in
here
try four that's two let's go three
i like that that's nice
um something else i want to look at here
is we talked about in the last video
about how
hard these edges are right if this was
a true newspaper it's going to be a
little bit um
gosh i'm not lost for words today
it was a long night last night a little
bit tired today um
so we just want some imperfections on
those edges right so how do we do that
well there's an easy way to do that we
just go up to effect
uh stylize and we'll go down to rough
and
edges this is a very powerful and often
underused effect
and just by adding it right there you
can see it's already
created some rough edges there right
but let's just let's minimize it so
we're going to take this down to
something like
four and the scale
maybe down to something like 20
and you can see there
how subtle it is but yet it works so
maybe
we'll go three three and 20. let's do
that
you can also play around some of the
different uh settings here like spiky
can sometimes be nice that is actually a
little bit nicer i like that
for this i'm gonna copy that and i'm
just gonna apply it to some of these
like this one
this could definitely use some rougher
edges
so we'll paste
yeah and depending on the size of the
image that's where we have to adjust
if one image is larger and a certain
setting of that effect works on that
larger image the same setting is
probably not going to work on a very
small image the settings are
going to have to be adjusted so looking
at this
maybe let's try a border of one
it just needs to be very subtle and that
that works for me there
japan here let's do the same thing
a little bit too much maybe 1.5
oh it's still too much
maybe a one no i actually liked it
better at 1.5 but maybe let's go back to
roughin
i think that'll work
let's go on to this image back here
same deal
yep works for me there let's do this
front one here
[Music]
uh well maybe they'll change this to
rough and
yup that works great this one
may not need let's go to ruffin as well
oh that looks nice i like that a lot
actually
and let's do this other front one here
go back to roughing
i'll see this is a much larger image see
how well it worked here on this image
looks great
maybe crank up the border here
now when i pre-composed cold war for
some reason it created like this
highlight edge here which i'm not
totally digging um and maybe that has
something to do
not quite sure if maybe a position
got moved uh you can see here see so the
cold war
they should be exactly the same i'm
looking at the y values here
so we're going to copy that y value and
paste it here
and there we go got rid of that weird
edge
you know it looks kind of interesting
but it's just it's not for me for this
particular
look i also think now i'm looking at
this hard light is
too much uh overlay
now completely gets rid of it so let's
undo yeah you know i'm going to stick
with hard light
that works
liking that a lot make sure yeah let's
get the
roughing edges on this one as well so
we'll actually go back to effect
roughen edges we'll decrease this to
1 and the scale down to 20.
something else you can a lot of times
play with is the complexity here
so um
if i was to play with the complexity
[Music]
oh maybe five let's just see what that
does
yeah that's a little bit more
interesting a little bit more
torn up on the edges yeah no
actually i'll say yes and i'll say no
ah that looks good subtle subtlety is
our best friend
and that is subtle and it's working and
what was this image right here
oh yeah i did like this one
it'd be nice to have something just
really kind of pushed back
in the background here i'll take it to
the bottom of my
layer stack here maybe scaling it up
if i take off that mask let's just see
change it from add to none
yeah maybe let's do let's cheat it a
little bit let's go to
color correction curves
and let's just really bring down the
actually the exposure color correction
exposure
we'll take off the curves here
you know what i think i like it better
with just the
mask part
actually that's kind of nice right there
i don't like the white border so i'm
going to open up my mask and you can see
this white border
see when i masked it i left a little bit
of that border there so if we actually
go to mask
expansion and just go negative it's
going to
pull that mask inwards and get rid of
that mask
that white edge of that mask so that's
nice
it'd also be nice to see a little bit of
depth on this with some
blurriness and some depth of field i'm
not going to actually add it
for this particular piece but it is
something that
might look nice and when you're messing
around with it
you know what i'm just going to
hide this layer i think it's not
necessary
yep looking pretty good
like that let's actually duplicate that
and bring this one back
so the same paper here but because we're
seeing only a part of it here on another
part here that's why this works
and i keep coming back to this image
here
because it's really in your face
maybe if i was to bring this text
up in here
this is all part of the polish right
just kind of playing around
i like that
i'm also going to apply an exposure
control to this one and just
kind of darken it up a little bit
yeah okay so that's where we're at there
looking pretty good let's go ahead and
add some effects to this
okay so let's add a new adjustment layer
and again we'll call this effects
one and to this we are
going to do a fastbox blur
and we're going to repeat edge pixels
and we're going to crank this up to
something like
50 and then by changing this down here
on the timeline now
from normal mode to screen it almost
creates like this
interesting well it does create it
creates an interesting glow effect
right so you can see it kind of brings
everything um
without using a glow effect this is kind
of a cheat for it right
so looks pretty interesting
might be too much but let's let's keep
adding some effects to this
let's do another adjustment layer
and you may be asking why am i using
multiple layers of adjustment layers for
effects and that's just so i have more
control if i want to
reduce like the transparency right so
let's just reduce the transparency of
this to
let's try 65. we'll see that adjusts
my overall glow so that's with
that's without so you know that looks
nice at 65 percent
so that's why i use different adjustment
layers because i can adjust transparency
for the
adjustment layers and adjust the effects
that way
next we're going to go in we're going to
add some grain again let's add some
grain here noise and grain
add grain final output
and we're going to make this heavy
grains we'll try this first one
[Music]
and boom look at that that looks really
nice just right there i'm good with that
next we're going to add some chromatic
aberration again so we'll go into
uh plug in everything quick chromatic
aberration 2. again if you don't have
this plug-in go to plug-in
everything and just search
quick chromatic aberration depending on
when you're watching this or maybe
another version of it
but uh that's all you have to do is
download it and you're good to go
so maybe yeah i was going to say maybe
red and green for this one
we're going to stick with the default
we're also going to blur this
just a hair and maybe give it a slight
rotation that's probably too much
yeah it's way too much maybe a point one
looks really interesting i like that
awesome
and let's do one more adjustment layer
here and we'll call this
i should call this color correction
we're going to go into effect
color correction a lumetri color it's my
favorite
coloring plugin that comes with after
effects
and we're just going to go into creative
and look
and we're going to pick number three
here
and it's going to desaturate this and
just give it a really nice
look we'll keep intensity at 100. maybe
let's again let's fade the film a little
bit here
and i like that a lot so we could like i
said we could adjust the
amount of glow here we want a little bit
more
that's really nice we could go less
i think i like it right where it was at
65 percent we're going to try one more
thing here
this is a film burn i thought would be
kind of interesting to bring in
this is a film burn from the texture
pack
for film textures from motion science
this was created with my buddy
ryan feiguard and this is an awesome
texture pack
and it's got a lot of film burns to it
but we could do something like maybe
this film burn
right here and all we have to do is just
set this to
something like screen
and it's gonna load up here and look at
that look how cool that looks
um you can you know just go through here
frame by frame and find something that
works for you there's a lot of different
film burns to pick from
but i absolutely love it um and i
actually like where it was at
so it just gives a nice interesting
texture to the the side over here
and so one other thing i mentioned right
when i first started designing these i
said i wanted to approach
the second concept it's one that i could
easily animate and just to show you
because i built this
in 3d space now i can easily
do things where i push in on the camera
i pull out on the camera and do things
like that and i have depth
already happening here so it's already
in the beginning stages
of animation at this point it's really
easy because i designed this in after
effects
i designed it i took the time to build
it in three and a half two and a half d
space
um i'm ready to start design to animate
if it gets approved so
there you go there's concept two for you
so there you go
that's how you bring it all together and
you deliver pro quality
style frames doesn't it feel good
knowing what you should focus on right
now
regardless of where you are in your
journey do you see how this clarity will
help you design pro level style frames
easier and faster
now that you've got these wheels turning
i want to hear
from you i know you picked up a lot of
ideas from this video
and now's the time to get started so
let's let me know
in the comments below this video what
you're going to do with this
and if you found this video helpful
others will too so please
feel free to share it on social media on
facebook on twitter
or even send the link to a friend in the
next video i'm going to show you
how to implement what you learned today
easier
and faster if you're a junior motion
designer this lays out the exact plan so
you can design
like a pro and if you're a mid-level
motion designer
you'll build on what you may already
know by following specific steps
designed to get you past
what's holding you back so you get on
track and you reach your goals more
quickly speaking of learning how to
design
i've been hearing from a number of
people who've had questions about
stylecraft
and i'd love to see you in there in the
next video
we'll talk more about this program and
how you can join
the way it works is that i open up the
full class
to the general public on a very limited
basis
i do this twice a year we do this so
that it runs similar to like a college
class where we all
go through this together so registration
opens for a few days
then it closes so i can create that
space
for the new members and i can deliver
the content
so if you're interested in moving
forward and want to know how
you'll want to definitely join me in the
next video where i lay it all out for
you
but for now i want to leave you with
this
just by taking part in this workshop
you're already closer to knowing how to
design pro level style frames think
about video one where you learned how to
concept
how the concept process works for style
frame design this
this training alone has shown you how
you can have a clear path to design and
it's amazing how simple it can be
once you have the steps then you made
big strides in video 2
where you saw how to easily build style
frame layouts
by using assets from the concepting
process and that's
huge and knowing this will continue to
pay off
from now and into the future and today
you got the complete rundown on how to
bring that
final polish to your style frames isn't
it easier understanding every step along
the way
to make it even better we cut to the
chase so you know exactly what gives you
bigger results faster and with less
demand
on you so in just a few days you've
learned so much about how to design
pro level style frames and in the next
video i'll share the next step on your
journey
i'm so excited about what's in store for
you
and i'll see you in the next video